this pantheistic God of the stoics is
identified with nature itself it is as
we said the active aspect of the world
which is part of all things but remember
the stoics are materialists so this God
is not something immaterial present in
the world but also somehow a physical
thing indeed it is also often called by
the term Puma which is often translated
as breath or fiery breath God is a kind
of fire not literally of course but in
the sense of being a very subtle kind of
matter similar to fire or
breath all these terms are often used
interchangeably by the stoics god nature
logos the whole Puma to denote the same
concept this monistic or pantheistic
idea of God
as some kind of unity that that is that
Unity that permeates all things